50 seconds of Sony and Marvel logos that
are only my second favorite combo of S&M
is it too much to ask to include
begrudging to this title card I mean
even Deadpool couldn't make that happen
but it's a perfect joke is like all
professional astronauts that are caught
in precarious situations the immediate
compulsion is to curse and scream I
don't care how dangerous the symbiote is
astronauts are king unflappable man
would it not be easier for someone to
just carry the symbiote case down the
ladder that's right King there and I'm
assuming the case can be handled since
it was picked up and put in the pulley
that's Sheamus pause for two seconds so
all comic book stands can gasp oh the
poor bastard must have just seen a bird
box demon they're ghosts alien are those
things anyway also evil killer wakes up
and is able to gather their bearings
while helpful medical worker is turned
away cliche in case you confused it with
San fransokyo big hero 6 - you were
perfect and also way too talented to be
in this movie I mean there's really no
time that San Francisco's this open but
this is the beginning of the day right
and Siro goddamn traffic it's on the
ground today in the Mission District
montage exposition hey man that's my
favorite position Eddie the bike MIT Wow
holy the last 50 seconds or so we firmly
established Eddie as a gadfly
malcontents social justice warrior that
excuse the rule of law for convenience
and yet has an affection for the little
man and that's way too much to cram into
50 seconds you know what I love about
this view it never gets old yeah because
all those Millennials keep disrupting
tech services launching startups and
driving all the older residents that can
no longer feasibly afford the house in
which they spent their entire life due
to rising ah he meant the view of the
bay
carry on you're just gonna ask him about
his space program you're gonna thank him
and you go to bid him a nice day damn
did Jack not see that 50 second montage
about Eddie's previous reporting
seriously as soon there are other
employees at this news organization that
are less known for exposing corruption
as their sole purpose in the company
anywhere run out in New York last lab
car see any organ don't be fooled by the
Hulk that he bought he still he's still
at it from the property I was going
places I wasn't running I was going
places rotations position it's like my
fifth favorite position
Valentine wait the screen savers still
on but they've already had sex and had
time to fall asleep I really is supposed
to be rooting for a guy that only lasts
that long also I don't know if there's a
laptop out there that shows the relevant
bulk of a confidential email while it's
on the screensaver which would be easy
to identify to any passerby but if there
is and if you own one of them viewer I'm
not a lawyer but there's not a chance in
hell a law firm with an account this big
would be emailing confidential reports
emails can be hacked
nobody boyfriends can open them up etc
this will be passed around and a private
boardroom meeting and collected
afterward before anyone left that guru
Wow not only is all the information
about brakes failed clinical trial
available in the exact same document it
just happens to come across Ann's
computer the night before any interviews
of I bet it's the subtle nuances like
this that made the movie a critical
darling mr. Drake
it's okay don't silence her man anyone
that's trying this hard to prove how
woke they are should immediately be
suspected of covering up a conspiracy to
import alien technology for capital
gains they try and silence those of us
who ask questions but you know what in
the end we're the ones who change the
world sir this is a windes 24 that's
still extremely young right you create
the life foundation is it a rule that
Tom Hardy only over acts in superhero
movies because noticing a trend here I
have a hunch we don't go off half-cocked
based on a hunch but half-cocked Brock
is a perfect title for his new show also
Brock has to know all - that's dumb and
uncaring as the movie makes Brock out to
beat going after Drake the way he did is
not a fitting character trait based on
what the rest of this movie shows us and
it's the foundation this whole movie is
built on that's at least ten sins worth
of bull ah movies where no matter how
long you're employed by an organization
the contents of your workspace will fit
neatly into exactly one cardboard box
what you did got me fired can you use to
me
wow that escalated quickly he's wearing
the same clothes so this is the same day
as the interview and even though Drake
has an ass-ton of power the firm's going
to immediately assume Eddie got the info
from an and fire her on the spot was a
fin law firm and they should know that
it's not kosher
beautiful is there really no concern
that this is only three of the four
highly unstable symbiotes and that one
of them is just traipsing the corral
Malaysia right now big riot a little
malaysia tough guy has got to be tough
but they saw what just happened right
her arm changed into a medieval sword
looking thing a decapitated a dude these
guys brought a knife to a symbiote fight
seriously six months nothing related to
this story occurred for six months I
mean even if the symbiote was outside
the US there would have to be some
reporting on its tomfoolery right like
even the incident the Malaysian village
didn't get pressed even though it was
right by the spaceship crash site making
human trials oh it's way too soon to
even begin to think about screw through
the forefront of a scientific
breakthrough I need you to hold your
nerve I like rosamma it a lot explain to
me how this character is any different
from Darren cross and ant-man or Norman
Osborn in spider-man or can Ajax in
Deadpool just because you have a likable
actor doesn't mean you can repeat the
exact same formula on every villain
Marvel Thank You Eddie broth I used to
mean goddamn this is so cliche you could
legitimately convince me that I'm
watching a scene from the later parts of
anchorman I'm expressing my inner
anguish through the majesty of song the
wife Foundation has now begun
preparation as this policy and hipster
bars across the country this TV is
turned up to full volume during an
interview with a tech CEO thank you
you're welcome
oh you're welcome not content to make
the villain as road as possible movie
imbues this suppose an antihero with a
ton of compassion for the less fortunate
and I could not be mourned even if this
asshole doesn't perceive Eddie as a
threat and he did see him when he walked
into the store and you know they do have
cell phones in this universe right also
why didn't he perceive Eddie as the
threat despite being told by movie he's
ultimately a weakling he also looks a
lot like Tom Hart not even asking to
staff there why would he do that I can't
use my name I can use a pseudonym it's
pretty late though right like definitely
nighttime when we established that Eddie
was at the bar and then he hung with his
homeless pal and picked up a sandwich at
the convenience store so why is he
calling for job interviews now I don't
care what fake-ass neighbourhood this is
it's still Sam fucking Francisco and an
apartment this big would set you back at
least 75 hundred a month
[Music]
huh I guess Eddie doesn't want to Brock
this is day one this is first contact
actually it's six months after the
symbiotes were collected so it's more
like day 186 but semantics what do you
see war poverty a planet on the brink of
collapse we interrupt this event a movie
to briefly bring you footage from first
performed I mean this is good CGI right
but it's also terrible right man I
haven't seen a Drake attempt failed as
hard since thank me later also once that
thing gets out of the tube how the hell
did they get it back in without someone
going into the room you have to know how
to disappear I was pretty good brave you
this may have been an essential part of
it he's former drop all we've seen from
the montage and the gotcha Drake
interview is that Eddie's a wrecking
ball not a scalpel so this is definitely
the venom calling the kettle black you
need to find yourself another white
noise I hear Aaron Eckhart's still
available seriously the hell is he done
since the dark night besides white
Olympus has fallen down what are you
doing here Eddie I'm here because I miss
you a lot
scuba nice gift also I'm all for
establishing backstory in all hood does
this movie ever gonna invent him the
closest we've gotten the first third of
the story is that poor Isaac bastard
open population and climate change these
are two things that Drake cannot control
yeah is this the first time these two
are talking about this cuz they had a
phone conversation met up to plan the
subterfuge and had to drive out to the
facility which were all chances to catch
up on the expository dialogue onboard
computers indicated the presence of life
I mean this is a very tech forward
building right is there really no
concern that this conversation is being
taped via video and/or audio we call
them symbiote stimulus well we did call
them symbiosis as of the first trailer
but bugs out of people so we did this
totally obvious ADR to cover it up got
it the door just taking all these
pictures and sent them to Eddie and
given an interview I'm honestly not sure
I understand why he needed to witness
the atrocity firsthand and there's a lot
less chance of anyone getting caught
before the story goes public Louie I'm
not making light of the fact that San
Francisco has a severe homelessness
problem but I am calling both on the one
homeless person that Eddie knows
personally is currently in the cell
here it also the alarms have been going
off for quite a while with zero response
from security I guess they're cool with
the potential breach of a dangerous
alien parasite remember that one that's
loose in Malaysia yeah good times
also also even if Security's not there
we're the doctor slave Cup she was only
supposed to distract that guard for a
couple of seconds right to the garage
guards not have a car are they just
expected to run from their posts every
time there's an issue that doesn't seem
efficient at all so this is just like
the indoor speeder chase in Return of
the Jedi except not good
what helped me go what all those guys
were running toward him and the two cars
were driving to him and not one person
saw or heard him climb all the way up
the street
holy newbie just yada yada how Eddie
escaped from that predicament how long
was he in the tree did security really
give up isn't the lab on an island if so
how'd he get off Jesus this movie
actually would have been good if they
tried like 22 percent harder you're
fired
but we won't have any investigation of
dr. Dora even though we can easily and
immediately determine that she let the
intruder into the lab because she was
super good in that movie about a little
girl that was good at math it's been six
goddamn months since all this went down
but this woman has just been wandering
the countryside eating people and no one
noticed
wait Dora knows that the symbiotes
escaped and that Eddie was at least
tangentially affected considering his
method of escape so why does she respond
that she's okay he's scientists always
making about themselves the movie can
speed back my ass but you can tell the
Tom Hardy's going for it and this scene
alone deserves us it off go home get
some rest I'll call you when your tests
run yeah but Eddie just straight up
crashed a fancy lunch spot assaulted
some fools vandalize the place then ate
a live lobster and there are no legal
repercussions to this and I've seen
movies revel in their locations but I
don't think I've ever seen one that San
Francisco is harder than this you have a
parasite they're not exactly sure how
you got it this hospital wicked cool
even let ex-girlfriends who are
attorneys reveal sensitive medical
information to the patient did anyone
explain how the symbiote knows English
while talking to Eddie I mean the host
from Malaysia wasn't speaking Malaysian
he's right but I need you to tell me who
was here with you I can't do no work on
the security system in the subpoena app
which must be from the 1920 seriously
there was camera footage of Bucky
killing Howard Stark but nothing caught
Bain and Harley Quinn last night opening
movie totally waste Jenny slate and that
is definitely a sin Teddy where's the
buff this scene is total manufactured
bull even Drake acknowledged that
whoever broke into the lab had been
infected so they know exactly where the
bug is and if that's the case why didn't
they just immediately tranq his ass like
Dan did back at the restaurant that's
the original tagline for this movie mr.
Drake
our subjects carrying the symbiote man
everyone is super casual about the
symbiote being loose seriously this guy
sounds as excited as a dude calling his
wife after picking up some milk of
magnesia at the drugstore he's achieved
symbiosis you seeing this yes we are and
well we'll never know how or why
we know it's convenient that the guy
whose life you destroyed six months ago
is the first person who has perfectly
been compatible with the symbiote and he
sees this reflection how exactly this is
a power or just a lazy scriptwriting
device to show us venom for the first
time I leaned toward the ladder and wow
what a lame way to show his venom for
the first time I get the Drake is a rich
and powerful guy but he can't get away
with launching militarized drones on a
crowded public street Kenny also at this
point several drones have exploded on
the streets of San Francisco so why are
all these cars continuing to car please
do not let him get away
thank God Drake says this because the
first time please bring me back my
creature and the second time do not let
him get away understand the trees
clearly didn't take look there have been
some scenes with some decent CGI in this
movie but this this is not one of those
scenes
oh no Eddie's trapped in the middle of
two bad guys Drive evil black SUVs
cliches eyes so many snacks apparently
when the full venom is unleashed so too
was a weird accent that wasn't at all
there and at his head I mean at this
point you're just wasting ammunition
right eye and you Jesus that's the deal
sounds as reasonable as Mexico will pay
for it I thought he's labs back and it's
worse than I thought
so I figured I'd call you and discuss it
rather than wait until I got ahold of
the guy with the actual medical issue
anyway it is peaceful up surprisingly so
considering you just noisily scaled one
of the most famous skyscrapers in the
city by tearing at its facade I know we
need an action sequence here and all but
are these assholes they swamp
if so who called them if they're Drake's
man how they did they know he was here
my point in his movie clearly started
with how the scene what I'm thinking
about why this scene
gene Simmons eat your tongue out I mean
lick your heart out wait King what a
knee not only picks this place to look
for Eddie even though he hasn't worked
here for over six months
there's also no perimeter set up by the
police to keep her out god damn this
movies aggressively don't right now sure
don't worry about these brave men in
uniform some of which are gravely
injured right now I mean don't even call
that it but how and why isn't everyone
on top of them right now like they were
a few minutes ago well
i watch suddenly alone Drake meet up
with a little girl that somehow I made
it into this secure lab without anyone
noticing it occurs to me that this scene
seriously feels like it's from a
completely different movie honestly I
had to check to make sure I didn't have
a different disc in there for a second
wait how is that he's still alive when
every time any of the symbiotes have
left a host the host has died look at
you ah yes they found the symbiotes
natural enemy a single glass pane
sliding door I don't know what the
hell's going on sure do you want to
maybe call someone about the obviously
alien substance that's stuck in your MRI
machine room I'm not insane what's
insane is the way humans choose to live
today Drake's infected and still alive
he's got everything he wants right so
why even go into the expository villain
mode just head out to space man where is
my symbiote I have no idea I don't know
but I guess he's on a smoke break with
whoever was supposed to properly mix
this audio what are you gonna do you're
gonna walk me to death this is a great
question considering they've killed many
people right there in the lab and had no
problem disposing of the bodies but in
Eddie's case they're gonna treat him
like Paulie and Christopher treated the
Russian on The Sopranos this launchpad
is hilariously close to a major
metropolitan area so why does dry it
kill his entire crew I know he can pilot
the spaceship on his own but doesn't he
want someone on the ground to help out
with logistics like Pam and was great at
logistics until she was decapitated we
won't destroy this wall yeah a fight
between two evenly matched creatures in
which we have no clue how one can defeat
the other also known as the Man of Steel
scenario and it must be a complete
coincidence that the CGI fight occurs at
night I got to see that accelerated
alien species still ultimately settle
things between each other with a little
punching and kicking Jesus and sure does
have the sound wave defense down pat how
did she even know where the sound
doohickey was and how to connect it to
the loudspeakers oh cool now the humans
are punching each other totally makes a
difference in my investment in the
outcome of sorry what's gonna happen if
the bad guys bad oh then I'm trying to
George Clooney riot Sandra Bullock this
is a perfect place to put our Skyfall
outtake but it's so exactly Skyfall but
instead I'm gonna award a 10 extra cents
well I appreciate it but this is a
little too late in the game for
apologies especially since I've sat
through nearly the entire thing
thankfully into the spider-verse saved
us from this nonsense being Stanley's
final movie cameo shine I mean does this
thug asshole wait for Eddie to walk in
here before he holds mrs. chin over the
coals you will be this office Legolas
faceless Steve won't you going down the
street yep this line is what got the
fanboys boners raging do with that what
you will okay so did then I'm eat the
entirety of the thug I understand
swallowing a head but not a whole body
right or is this like Wolfenstein where
the bodies just disappear after you kill
them now get out of here and I will
there's gonna be double Skippy
hey Parker Oh my spider-sense is
tingling space says the introduction to
The Hitchhiker's Guide is big really big
[Music]
come on touch it huh come on you need
human contact touch it I will not touch
it okay for the record would hit it
Maria the most beautiful song you have a
brain tumor it's not a tumor